What is the best thing to do for dizziness or dizziness?
Well, like any symptom you always want to ask that
Hunting question of why so why you'll have dizziness. That's what you want to treat
You don't want to just treat the dizziness
Why is it there? So you know, you'll do a differential diagnosis diagnostic workup on a person that has a symptom like that
I have dizziness. Well, when do you have dizziness and let me stand from sitting down?
Well, you get up on a bed. Is it no, you know, it's just a different times I just feel off and dizzy those the answers to those questions are going to pinpoint us in different directions.
First, I'm going to have dizziness because of neurological, you know, issues they could even have, you know,
eat a little carpractor and get their neck adjusted. That could be an issue.
But you start thinking about circulatory things with dizziness as well.
You think of neurological inflammation with dizziness. That's common.
If they have dizziness upon a rising and then it calms down right away. I just have to hold myself when I stand up.
You start thinking of adrenal insufficiency because your adrenals are supposed to kick in and raise your blood pressure about 10 points from the city to a standing position.
So you can easily measure that if you have a really good blood pressure cuff.
I measure my blood pressure city down. I stand up and measure keeping the cuff on measure right away.
Again, if blood pressure drops or does not rise, 10 points, then that's an adrenal insufficiency test.
So that could be it could be a blood sugar problem. That's a common issue for dizziness.
People with diabetes and blood pressure blood sugar issues can have dizziness.
So you have to figure out why is what I'm saying. So it's not a matter of, oh, is there a program for dizziness on the right.
If I'm just going to run that, well, you got to get to the reason why if you would be to run some tests to do that or at least answer some questions to try to figure out.